naruto is one of the most popular anime
franchises of all time with over 940
episodes in the naruto series and
multiple movies new fans may feel
overwhelmed we'll explain the correct
order in which to experience the
sprawling naruto
you can do this believe it
naruto opens with mischievous naruto
defacing a mount rushmore-esque cliff
portraying the hidden leaf village's
elders at the time he's a goofy
troublemaker friendless and pathetically
unskilled
unsurprisingly he's mocked by his
classmates especially his crush sakura
who's in love with the ultra cool sasuke
but soon enough things turn around for
naruto he becomes a shinobi gets on a
team with sakura and sasuke taught by
the impressive kakashi rescues sasuke
from a seemingly undefeatable foe
destroys all expectations in the chunin
exams defeats a tailed beast and takes
on a legendary ninja as his sensei plus
he learns the rasengan one of his most
powerful moves
since team seven is still together in
the first naruto movie ninja clash in
the land of snow it must take place
before sasuke leaves in episode 108 it
must also occur before the mission that
begins in episode 102 which results in
sasuke's injury furthermore naruto has
the rasaingun so it has to take place
after episode 96 as sakura is in episode
99 and all three are together in
hiddenly village in episode 101 this
would be the perfect place for them to
go on their snow mission with all that
in mind this movie is a whole lot of fun
it introduces some cool hidden leaf
village ponchos features killer snow
stream battles unveils some of kakashi's
best jutsu and culminates in naruto's
multi-colored rosengan
this run of naruto episodes contains one
of the most compelling arcs in the
series naruto and his fellow genie or
junior ninjas set off to bring sasuke
back led by the recently promoted
shikamaru
each young shinobi fights high above his
level in this storyline which also
introduces cooperation with their new
allies the three sand siblings
furthermore the arc ends in naruto's
first great showdown with sasuke in the
naruto manga this arc is what ends young
naruto's story most of what follows in
the anime is considered filler you could
skip the next 60 episodes if you're only
looking for canon but we advise
otherwise why give up on what ends up
being a whole lot of fun this is a
really unique movie because it brings
naruto sakura shikamaru and kankuro
together also it includes heavily armed
battleships and soldiers neither of
which appear in the series proper while
there aren't signposts in the filler
episodes that might help identify where
the naruto movies fit after sasuke's
departure there are some fan theories
about their order one says stone of
galel takes place after episode 147
because the movie originally premiered
at the same time as mizuki strikes back
supporting this is the fact that naruto
and shigamaru work together during this
arc it makes sense then that they
continue that cooperation in this film
other fans maintain stone of galel
occurs after episode 160 ultimately it's
up to you
this stretch of naruto contains more fun
filler episodes though none feature any
developments vital to the central story
some viewers suggest powering through
the series by skipping episodes 143-219
but if you do so you'll miss episodes
that showcase characters deepening bonds
and growing skills if the whole point of
watching naruto is to be entertained
this run delivers
the final movie of the original naruto
series crescent moon kingdom is most
notable for replacing sasuke with rock
lee and showing off the team's new warm
weather outfits guardians of the
crescent moon kingdom is placed after
episode 196 because it was released
around the same time as that episode
plus scenes from the movie made it into
the opening of episodes 197-199
but again both naruto movies guardians
of the crescent moon kingdom and legend
of the stone of gal-el could
theoretically be thrown anywhere as long
as they end up among the many filler
episodes that finish the series
naruto ends with yet more filler
episodes these episodes are usually a
flashback to backstory a mission with
people from different teams thrown
together to hone their skills a display
of strengthening alliances or an
exploration of a what-if scenario
episode 220 in which naruto leaves with
the legendary saanin jiraya is tied to
the same event in the comics and is
therefore canon if you're looking to
speed through the series jump to this
episode
naruto shipuden opens from the point of
view of an unseen person running down
mysterious corridors we've jumped almost
three years into the future from the end
of the first series it's a bit confusing
but from the moment heroes come back by
japanese hip-hop group nobody knows
starts to play over the series first
opening sequence it's impossible not to
get excited the series opens with a bang
as the akatsuki attack hidden sand
village capturing gara decimating the
sand forces and almost killing konkoro
naruto is more mature sakura is
significantly stronger and all their
young friends have aged up into
formidable shinobi plus naruto has
upgraded his blue and orange outfit to a
sleek black and orange look
unfortunately the naruto shipuden movies
can be even tougher to fit into the
right order than the original naruto
flicks not only are there simply more
episodes and arcs to sort through some
of these movies have serious
inconsistencies with the canon story
that said this one is relatively easy to
fit naruto shipuden the movie premiered
during the kazekage rescue arc which
ends at episode 32. in this movie we see
a team made up of naruto sakura rock lee
and neji neji is the only person from
their class who's reached the elite
status of jonine like many other naruto
movies grand salvation occurs in this
one thanks to a special version of
naruto's rasengan
in these episodes team 7 is reformed
with sai an untrustworthy but powerful
ninja from the mysterious foundation who
becomes sasuke's permanent replacement
captain yamato a former on-boo black ops
ninja is brought in to head the team in
place of an injured kakashi in this run
we see more of the akatsuki's plans more
about donzo's techniques and even a
reunion between naruto and the now
frighteningly powerful sasuke the scene
depicted in the opening to this new
series
the most notable elements of naruto's
shipuden the movie bonds are its
airships a very advanced technology and
a zero tails neither of which are ever
mentioned before or after this movie
since episodes 70 and 71 are non-canon
you can watch this after either of those
before you return to canon storylines at
72. what happens in this flick well
orochimaru is sick and sasuke is still
doing his bidding which brings him
together with naruto as they take on a
man who may have a technique that could
help the ailing orochimaru this limits
the film to happening before episode 114
when sasuke and orochimaru's
relationship comes to a head
a lot happens in this stretch of
episodes here we witness the death of a
major sensei the rise of the new ino
shika cho team and naruto inventing a
new super powerful jutsu though the
second half of this run from episode 91
to episode 112 is considered quasi-canon
it does contain a tailed beast which
makes some impact on the storyline you
should give this a watch
will of fire is one of the few movies
with references to things from the
series which make it clear that it has
to take place after the kakashi
chronicles episodes which end with
episode 120. also naruto sai and sakura
break village rules and follow kakashi
an act of disobedience sai would only
have been able to commit after some time
spent with team seven in will of fire
shinobi boasting keke genkai abilities
have been stolen from everywhere but
hiddenly village casting suspicion upon
the villagers when kakashi is compelled
to leave the village through a
mysterious curse implanted in him
tsunade allows him to go as an act of
self-sacrifice but as previously
mentioned team 7 follows joined by other
teams in support
there is a huge death in this run one
that hits naruto especially hard the
akatsuki also seriously increased their
activity and jiraya is haunted by a
student from his past in an especially
important flashback jiraiya even offers
the viewers a major revelation as to
naruto's parentage sasuke finally gets
the revenge that has motivated him for
most of his life and realizes he knew
nothing in the aftermath he joins the
seriously dwindled akatsuki this stretch
of episodes contains an arc some fans
call filler which actually ends up
having a big role in later episodes
bottom line these episodes are impactful
and important
naruto shippuden the movie the lost
tower has to occur within a very small
window of canon it happens after the
death of a major character but before
that person's killer launches a tragic
attack naruto discovers this heavy death
in episode 152 helps the village deal
with the investigation in episode 153
and episode 154 and is transported to a
far off land for secluded training in
episode 155 so this movie has to happen
between 154 and 155 the lost tower
features an interesting naruto yamato
time travel element in which our hero
comes face to face with the ninja the
audience now understands to be his
father moreover the action scenes and
animation are amazing
a powerful akatsuki member reigns
devastation on hiddenly village while
naruto is off training when naruto
returns we see the troublemaker whom
everybody once despised finally gaining
the admiration respect and love of
hiddenly village
we also learn about the power of a new
ocular jutsu known as the renegade a
keke genkai ability a few steps up from
the byakugan and sharngan meanwhile the
akatsuki lose the man we'd long believed
to be their leader as it turns out the
once foolish toby is actually much more
astute than we'd ever imagined
[Applause]
of all the movies in the series this is
the toughest to place due to
inconsistencies the rykage still has
both arms yet naruto knows killer b
neither of which occur at the same time
in the series those inconsistencies
aside the fact that naruto has mastered
sage mode and knows who his father is
places the movie after payne's attack on
hiddenly village plus it has to happen
before the 5 cage summit arc which
starts at episode 197 so we're putting
blood prison after episode 196 with the
caveat that this movie is so non-canon
it might be impossible to truly pinpoint
blood prison is also unique in that
naruto isn't joined by any of his
hiddenly village friends for the
majority of the film as a result he has
to make new allies within the prison
where he's wrongly incarcerated
though road to ninja naruto the movie is
technically non-canon it has some
relevance as it's a depiction of what
toby's genjutsu world would really look
like in road to ninja naruto and sakura
are transferred to toby's infinite
tsukuyomi world where naruto's parents
are still alive and sakura's parents
died defending the village naruto
already met his mom in episode 246 so
his ability to identify her in the movie
places it after the end of that arc in
episode 251 episode 252 begins the
run-up to the shinobi war with toby too
busy trying to attain nagato's renegade
to cast the infinite tsuko yomi so this
movie has to happen between episodes 251
and 252
this massive run of 240 episodes is
impossible to properly describe in a
timely fashion here we encounter the
fourth great shinobi war naruto and
sasuke's final battle and naruto's
ascendancy to a status unimaginable to
anybody who knew the boy growing up
these episodes feature amazing battle
after amazing battle creating an
absolutely jaw-dropping storyline that
goes toe-to-toe with the greatest anime
sagas around though again episode 311
should be watched immediately after 251
not in its series order
the last naruto the movie is the only
canon naruto movie this movie takes
place after the great shinobi war and
naruto's showdown with sasuke but before
the final arc that takes place from
episode 494 through episode 500. this
movie also jumps forward a couple years
bringing naruto into young manhood so
between episodes 493 and 494 it is
this run of episodes closes out shipuden
it's a couple years after the great
shinobi war and there are lots of good
feelings going around it's been a long
journey 720 episodes and 10 movies long
to be precise and the troubled no good
boy ninja with a demon inside him has
become the greatest shinobi in the land
these episodes benefit from that fact
naruto's story doesn't end there he and
his wife hinata have a son named boruto
as with the original series baruto
naruto next generations is based on a
manga created by masashi kishimoto which
follows a new boy ninja growing up in
the shadow of his father's greatness
episodes 1 through 49 chronicled
boruto's life as he makes his way in the
academy and his early days on team
konohomaru though naruto was a horrible
student and a social pariah in his early
days beruto's journey is very different
from his father's
in this movie baruto has graduated from
the academy and joined team konohomaru
with sarida and mitsuki the story told
here is also explored in the series so
if you prefer you can watch episodes 50
through 65 and check out the movie after
or skip the movie entirely the movie was
released before the series and is an
adaptation of the beruta manga making it
canon take note there are some details
of this story that differ between movies
and series
the adventure continues berudo's path to
becoming a great shinobi is certainly
different from his father's but taking
it in is just as fun and memorable the
show is still running and given the
length of the previous series that might
remain the case for a very long time for
however long this saga remains ongoing
devoted fans will flock to it eager to
enjoy the adventures of these powerful
fighters check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about naruto are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]